:)Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to three simulator games!
There's a lot of simulator games out there on the internet---. There's Euro Truck Simulator. There's going to the bathroom simulator...
There's a simulator for pretty much anything that you would want to do.
So I've collected three of them.  I have no idea if they're good,
I have no idea if they're bad some are new some are very old. the first one is called Grass Simulator!
And I don't know what grass simulator is - okay??
I hit mode select. I didn't hit start game. I don't know what-what are we doing?
*funky dunky music*
Okay anyway, we're gonna just play classic cuz I don't know if I can hand- oooooh kay.
Ah, yes, okay, what is that does that give me more or less time in this hellhole? Oh?
*laugh* Oh, it just makes things go slower...
OH. I should've known!
Ah, this is what I wanted even more time to experience the Joy of [ creation? ]
GRASS SIMULATOR [ well nice ]
Oh, God. Okay alright, how long does this last?
Am I sprinting now? I honestly can't - why is there a bench in the middle of this alka - What was that?
Oh, I guess I'm fine now..... alright,  Well, That's just great. I don't even wanna know....
Does that speed things uUp?
It does nothing [ fantastic XD ]
Well fool on me for assuming that this might have done something okay, alright, then oh
I should have known I would have a gun in the-! Oh...
All right, are you okay?
Am I supposed to try to shoot you when you pop your head up for a fraction of a second??
Ooh close one! Oh come on!
All right well, this ri-goddamn-diculous
But I am impressed by the bullet casings coming out of this gun with unlimited ammo. Okay. Well, I think I've made my point.
OH!
Of all the things that I expected to happen that was not one of them!
I don't even want to know what all the other modes of this game are. Do I -oh?
*light chuckle* O-oh! Ah!~
Oooh, responsive, very -ooh of course one-handed tommy gun!
Of course, that-that sounds correct.  WaaBABABABA!!
Always like to hold my guns at dick-heights, then everyone knows I'm in - Oh, all of their heads...
*chuckle* I don't think so. I disagree.
What else do I have? Do I have anything else? No?-
OOOOH!!!!!!
*guffaw*
I can zoom in with my mace, hAAAhAAAA!!!!
I can really aim good on this one. Get ready for your ass to get whumped!
*whump*
Uh-huh
Just checking your prostate. How does that feel? Huh all right your reflexes are very bad, okay?
I'm just gonna whump on your ass for a little bit here. All right is this supposed to be doing some okay?
Mmmm.....HM!!!
What's with this rubber gun!?
I- I payed money for this game..
*higher voice* I payed real money!..
This wasn't a free-to-play game no no no no no I paid real money
For the privilege of grass simulator, and I still don't understand what it has to do with simulating grass
I don't like that at all
I don't like the- what're you doing tree. What are you doing? That's not right?
What are you reaching for tree? We'll go to the main men-
All right, let's go to dubstep mode
*quality dubstep plays*
Oh
Oh, oh, whoa? What what? What, what, what? what!?
Okay, all right well, I'm fucking out of here. I'm out. I'm outie! okay, all right snow fall.
Ah, Skyrim well this looks actually good
Well that still works, but this looks really nice and detailed and.. well desig- okay nevermind then I
It's tripping a bit. It's very slippery out here on the ice
Yeah, I wish I could stop falling for one second on this staircase, but alright oh
Hi
Hello, how okay excuse me again very slippery all right, okay?
It slipped okay, alright, just gonna keep
Well alright, I guess. That's if I jump. I can't slip right oh, no edge of the world
What was the point of this? What was the point of it you're gonna tell me frosty? What was the point of all this?
Oh, you holly-jolly bear. Okay? I
Died over go this way, then oh, no you know what I regret going this
We got everything regret everything I regret everything
Everything is what I regret. Why are you spinning stop spinning? I have no weapons anymore. I don't understand it
I guess I'm just gonna
You know accept that this is just life
And I'm just gonna perpetually trip on my ass and fall flat on my face where the hell does this lead does this lead anywhere
It's just leading to anything am I going somewhere
Can you help me please help please? I'm begging you to help me. Oh boy. It's got to lead somewhere, right?
It's not just gonna run into another invisible wall. I mean oh
Never mind all right moving on next one
Hellfire what is oh?
oh
I am fast
All right well that funny guy range, I don't know what the range okay? Oh, ah
Yes of course oh
It's ah it's wonderful. I can practice my aim for my fortnight games ah
Good to know I'm still bad Wow oh
There's another room. Oh boy
Awesome, okay great. All right. I'm leaving now. Okay bad disco. Oh
We'll come at me, bro
Okay, oh my god. I don't get it. I don't get it. I don't get it
I don't get it nice guy. I guess is that stars that spit on my monitor. That's being illuminated
Okay, all right
There's only one more thing and it's online and
Yeah, let's do this
Yeah, okay, let's do it in the disco. Yeah, okay, let's do this come on. What is this?
What what
Is this
Someone, please play grass simulator with me. It's all my grandma got for me for my birthday
Oh, I can't believe this isn't at the top of everyone's list. Oh, I got a
Good where what knife? Yeah, come here wait. There's so many weapons
Wait why are there so many more weapons here than there were before
What?
Well, there's an RPG
You know I don't think anyone's gonna join my game. I can't leave I can't I cannot leave there we go okay
All right, I'm gonna leave now
Well that was the first one
All right, so if you thought that was great if you thought that was something special then boy
Do I have a game for you, yes, it's true you can finally
build a computer
On a computer. Yes, I know
Technology is accelerated to a point beyond which we currently understand and lo and behold
Not only are you able to build a computer?
But you're able to build a living off of
Building and repairing computers for other people in a game when I tell you about this game
Know that I'm not exaggerating in any capacity. Yes, you really can
Build a computer in a video game it yes. You really can
Make a living so here we go on a brand new adventure
Probably my new career for realsies to begin go to your PC by the doorway an open email program on your desktop
You've got mail. Oh
Wow, I'm so happy
So happy Wow whoa?
Blowing
Wow
jeolban at all the male comm
virus scan
PC can boot to OS remove viruses not plugged in well
Let's plug this bad boy in I'm gonna work on this, PC
You need to run a virus scan press 3 or the cable button and plug the monitor keyboard power and Mouse in the back of
the
Want this one ok I got it you know it, I've got it there we go Oh
like a dream
Like a dream. Oh yeah. Oh, this is the good stuff. Oh run an HDMI hoove
What are we plebs here? Where's my?
DisplayPort oh
Alright, you get over there wow that cable should not be going through the monitor should it okay?
Let's turn her on let's log on the computer
my computer click add/remove programs
Install the virus scanner and don't forget to restart the PC after it has been installed. What is my life?
Oh, I need to plug the USB in do I have a
Program mmm. Let me look. Let me look on my shelf oh
I wonder what components that I should use
Whew
I need to find I need to get some sort of like a USB stick that has like the program on it, right
I don't know
Where that would be?
Okay, do I have it here?
email
Thanks for taking over the PC shop for me. Sorry
It's not in the better state a few things the company isn't doing very well, so there's no money in the bank
Thanks, thank you great the rent and energy bills come out monthly so make sure you have enough money for them oh great
Wonderful. I'm so glad. I took this over
I had a job on the go
Which should help with the rent see the email below
Remember to use your thermal paste when putting on a CPU I almost always forget in the PCs overheat. Oh my god
Do I have an inventory oh?
There this that how do I do that?
Okay, oh, oh, oh oh
Here we go, but this yes. I did it. Did I do it. I did it okay
What happens if I just yank these goddamn fucking wires all over the plate? Oh shit ah
Oh all better now okay, I got it. I did I inserted it it's in there. Oh
It's not in there anymore. Oh shit. Ah fuck. God damn it okay, all right? Oh oh
That was way too sexual for my own good there, so let's scan this virus and let's let's build this career up
Let's pay our rent come on. Uh oh
We start now yes go
It's so realistic all right. Let's do this Wow that is not realistic at all oh
Boy five hundred to 500
Just as easy as that oh, just as easy okay all done
Alright place it in my corridor. Let's shut you down are we?
Loaded
Hey there I just wanted to say thank you for Oh
It's booting faster than it has in years. I didn't realize your uncle had gone away looks like okay
Can you stop please everybody stop? I just started. I don't know what I'm doing. Please leave me alone uh
Looks like the business is in good hands. Oh, that music is too loud music player. Can you?
Blissful silence
This is how I like my game in
complete and utter silence in fact
I'd rather have there be some creepy ambiance over this because there's something inherently creepy about pretty much
everything that I'm doing here, so
Let's have a scream
Oh
very nice
Okay, now. That's better all right. I need some more space to back up my files
Could you install a 500 gigabyte hard drive along my existing Drive?
I'll bring it round first thing first thing what first thing tomorrow first thing as soon as I responds his email
broken graphical card
Okay
remove viruses clean out dust
Yeah, I'm gonna go with this one. We're gonna dentist. Oh, it's gonna be disgusting. I'm gonna tip this over
There's gonna be teeth falling out of it
Okay, customers PCs will take a day to arrive so end the current day by going to the workshop door okay
Do it all let's do it all, but I'm doing the dusting first. Let's do it all all right. They're in transit
Okay, all right wow. What a satisfactory day. I'm so happy go to work. Oh Oh
Scan hello
I'm gonna scan it hello. Here you go. There you go
There I'm so happy
I'm so happy wait hang on wait a minute
I'm trying. I'm really trying. You're oh
I did it oh
Oh, it's doing it. There's just no sound to it. Ah why isn't there a sound?
added a sound
Here it is
There we go all right, she's a beaut she's a goddamn beaut all right
Let's let's put her back together put that back on
Screw er in nice and tight
and
Yes, I feel good about my life. All right. Let's install the old virus
And doing okay
all right look
You know these people shouldn't trust me with their computers
Especially full unrestricted access to their computers like this cuz that's a problem
That is a goddamn problem
Okay easy peasy let's you know let's go the extra mile. Let's delete this all right
Just because I'm such a good guy. I'm such a good guy looking at every little nuance of these people's computers, right?
No
God I'm so nice. This is really my life. I am legitimately
Just
Literally put, I don't know like reality hit me for a second there like all the sudden. It was like I am playing a game
Where I am literally fixing a computer something?
I do enjoy doing in my life
But not something I occupy my spare time with I I really
Really AM questioning my own sanity at this point. Why why am I still playing? Why am I still playing?
Why would I still play be playing this game? Why would I say can I can I please blow this?
Okay all right okay, all right. Let's remove. Oh wait. I can't all gotta undo the cable
I can't away
Undo the cable no, that's not what I wanted to do
How do I how do I undo the cable?
We're gonna pick up old fuck all right I picked it all off me happy alright. Let's remove it wait
Oh, No Oh Oh No
Why do I have to buy it?
Why do I why do I have to buy it that means? It's not gonna come today same-day delivery perfect my purchases
Wow
Thank you. Thank you. I'm gonna lose money on this job. Thank you. All right well
let's work on this PC ah
Man broken, let's sell that shit alright put you in there whomp easy peasy lemon squeezy
Alright, they seem to be overlooking the entire
Everything goes wrong hearts DOA unless that is a thing that can happen in this game because parts
arriving dead dead on arrival DOA
That is a very extremely thing that happens
Which is also words English that I did where's the power button on this fuck there it is
alright, did that does it boot it boots you have any porn on this computer and
Come with me don't even need to shut it down normally just flap do that alright one more
Got upgrade okay, alright wink okay boink again? What am I doing?
I don't have oh God
There it is okay by the current through the current same-day delivery
Plan ahead
Get that right put it in the commuter doodly-doo
This why have horror music playing over this okay?
Let's take this over here remove that scoodle you do a Scootaloo do that sound there okie?
Dokie, what if I just harvest all their shit and just sell all their shit for scrap? What are they gonna?
Do I'm sorry your computer was lost to the wind like what would happen if I actually did that oh?
Okay, I'll put you right there. All right. Did I do it oh?
Shit, that's not right
That's not what you call correct, okay, let's uh, let's take off the other panel
Let's do that now okay, all right. I'm ready right next to the other one baby. You got it put that bad boy right there
Right there. Oh yeah there
We go easy peasy man that cable management is nice. All right put that bad boy
This is the front one put that bad boy right there get the other okay, nevermind
I go screwing the bad boy before I can move on to the other bad boy all right move on to this bad boy put
That bad boy in there. Let's screw on that bad boy. That's a good bad boy. All right. Let's boot this bad boy
All right, how many times can I say the words bad boy before it starts to lose all Manning?
Let's put this bad boy right. Oh, come here bad boy. Let's turn on this bad boy. Oh
oh
Hell yeah, Oh got any porn on here there must be like some horrible secret Easter. Egg right there's got to be some horrible horrible
horrible secret Easter egg, right
collect mum Barney
I think I lost money on that same day. Delivery boink all right bro can grab his gun boink
Give me some help Mike got it account overdrawn. Hey here at mega Corp
We know that life doesn't always run smoothly, so we provide a free overdraft to our
Customers, that's not that's not realistic at all that's not at all realistic oh
I can't I'm done. I'm done. I can't play this game anymore. I can't do it  *adorable rage*
I imagine that there's some people out there that would love and adore this game and play it for hours and hours and hours
I'm not one of those people I have to leave I have to go now okay
I've got one more simulator game for you here, and it is called Beast battle simulator now
There's another game that came out a while ago, and if you know all about ultimate epic battle simulator totally accurate battle simulator
It's kind of like all those, but um I've never played it before so I'm gonna do the ice lake
Yeah, let's go that one. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know how this game goes
I I saw pictures of it, and it seemed absolutely ridiculous from what I was saying
But then I get a lot of these things seem ridiculous and turn out to be well completely, but oh my god. Ah
Go
On how how how how what the fuck oh?
my god oh
my god
Okay, alright. Well I didn't expect that alright. You're gonna get it with loose Eagles
Holy shit, holy shit, holy shit oh
My god oh
My god. This is way cooler than I ever thought it'd be oh wait no no no no I already bought
Waves to put up any sort of a fighting
So cool, I'm sorry. This is super cool. All right wait okay hang on wait. I got it. Okay so Dino, right?
It's t-rex right okay, so we got Oh where's Jeff Goldblum. Oh come on. There's got to be Jeff Goldblum. Oh?
Shit alright, let's do this. Let's do this
Uh-huh, I ain't so sure about this one huh, it's Don Zimmer. Yeah, I
Want to start out small before I go into anything like crazy and huge okay wait okay, you got a Jeep
let's put one human in there a space mage I
Can't put him in there. Oh come on
Swordsman. Oh come on all right. Well. That's Jeff Goldblum
This is
How did I not play this game sooner, this is amazing I love it all right now
We're gonna go into the ridiculous crossbow bed oh
shit in the form of a penis all right and then farm age in the form of
Yeah, okay all right go go. Oh boy. Well that lag. Oh, okay?
Who'd have thought this game isn't very optimized it seems to hmm seems to be a lot of problems
Lag and whatnot okay? Well that is that is an issue. I I think we have the matchup. We've all been wondering about
ostriches
vs
Megalodon Oh
Close
It wasn't even close
You're gonna get Maggie. You're gonna get Megalodon. Oh, Oh you go get it. Oh you think oh
Oh, oh, oh, oh you think you think you could okay. They just seem okay
They're just jumping into your mouth at this point there. Oh
Oh
Fuck oh. Yeah a hand let me get a different map. Let me let me get exit level. This is awesome
All right
challenges take down the penguin squad oh
Okay
Shark go no shit one shark all I need slide in our mouth motherfucker. Oh shit oh
Oh, I think they won
Compy ah
Many compy go can't be gonna get you. Hey oh
Wait oh
These penguins are powerful
This bank words are too. Good. Well nevermind this coffee is on a rampage. Holy shit alright. Yeah, I got to take you over
Rahr Rahr you can't beat my spins of death all right
You know what fuck that shit these dumb sharks think sand is water
Okay
Let me try - oh boy. Okay, you give me $10,000. Well. That's your problem because I have
Big squawker all right big squawkers whoa oh oh oh that's not right
What's happening, but they're on fire these guys shouldn't have messed with the fader oh my god, oh
My god the phoenixes are amazing oh, they're dead nevermind
What does this mean a variety of animals are seeding your Tower in the desert survive the waves
I don't know if I want to round one donkey elephant and t-rex
Oh wait, I can weaponize it but can I oh no, can I attach those to get an S
Wait wait wait wait wait wait wait I can weaponize
my giraffe
And a dog oh
Wait wait wait wait, but that where are they spawns bond
That's not elbow oh
It's oh no the giraffe is too high up you can't hit him. Oh, No okay? Oh, no. It's a tiny dog
The brave pooper
The brave pup er okay? Well we're all done here. Let's
Let's set beasts on fire
BAM
Blizzard
Mears oh shit well, we're fucked early. Oh boy. This is a laugh and a half that did nothing
Oh, that's that's a problem. Okay giraffe feet t-rex. It's like what I said in the beginning of this yes
Yeah giraffe beats t-rex fuck. Oh Jesus laser. No know what that is, but I'm just gonna do all
all dogs
alright
Let's go. Let's go. Let's go bitches. Let's go. Let's go get him get him get him get him get a puppies
Come on please please
Oh
Boy oh boy, this is the best thing I've ever seen oh this is great great. Oh shit
Okay, I'm done. Okay. I'm done alright
Get it out alright. That's all for Beast battle simulator. That's fun. That's fun that good girl
Very quickly, but that was pretty fun, so thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know you thought down the comments below if you want to play any of these simulation games
I'll provide links in the description below and
Let me know if there's any other cool simulator games that you want me to play in the future
Thanks again, and as always I will see you in the next video